moscow has always denied playing any
part in the poisoning of the former
russian spy sergei skripal and his
daughter yulia or the assassination of
alexander lipvinenko denials that have
been met with incredulity here and in
the west but this morning the united
kingdom has upped the stakes by naming
and charging a third russian military
intelligence officer over the salisbury
poisonings just as the european court of
human rights ruled that russia was
responsible for the murder of alexander
litvinenko
scotland yard believes dennis sergei
entered the uk under the alias sergei
fedotov two days before the salisbury
attack and met several times with the
other two russian agents
it is the first time that he's been
named officially as a suspect
now he's a reminder of the timeline of
events in salisbury
on the 4th of march 2018
the former russian double agent sergey
skripal and his daughter yulia were
found unconscious on a park bench in
salisbury shortly afterwards police
confirmed they'd been poisoned with a
nerve agent
on the 8th of march it was announced
that a police officer detective sergeant
nick bailey was seriously ill in
hospital after attending the incident he
was later discharged from hospital
on the 12th of march the prime minister
theresa may told the house of commons
that the nerve agent was a russian
origin and was highly likely that russia
was responsible for the poisoning
on the 30th of june after julia and
sergey skripal were discharged from
hospital
dawn sturgis and charlie rowley fell ill
in amesbury eight miles from salisbury
and were taken to hospital police later
confirmed they'd been exposed to
novichok
on the 8th of july dawn sturgis died in
hospital
and on the 5th of september scotland
yard and the crown prosecution service
announced there was sufficient evidence
to charge two russians
alexander petrov and ruslan boshirov
with charges relating to the nerve agent
attack
the following week alexander petrov and
ruslaf boshirov were interviewed on a
russian state-funded news channel where
they claimed they were just tourists
visiting wonderful salisbury to look at
its cathedral amongst other items well
our security and defense editor deborah
haynes joins us now from new scotland
yard and
deborah a third charge but none of these
people
under arrest or able to be brought to
justice at the moment
now all three of the suspects are
believed to be in russia but make no
mistake this is a significant
development in a in a case that has
lasted more than three and a half years
with the police very much still keen to
ensure that everyone that they believe
is involved is finally brought to
justice they say
and this is the first time not only for
them to name this third suspect a name
than a sergey that has been widely
reported before the investigative
website bellingcat first broke that name
a couple of years ago and sources have
always indicated that there was a third
suspect but this is the first time that
the police have come out and named him
said that they have the ability now to
to charge him and have also said that
the three individuals are all members of
the gru russia's military intelligence
agency it's the first time the police
have said they've got the evidence to be
able to say that an allegation that
you'll remember theresa may made back in
september 2018 when she first called out
those first two suspects in relation to
this case and another interesting
element to this that's important to talk
about the police are saying that these
three men have been part of a three-man
team and they've worked together in
other countries and we know that um
dennis sergey has been accused by the
bulgarian authorities of a poisoning of
of a bulgarian arms dealer in 2015 and
we also know that the two other suspects
are are wanted by the czech authorities
in relation to an explosion at an arms
depot in the czech republic in 2014 so
this really is further evidence of what
british security sources believe is a
unit known as 29155
that's suspected of conducting acts of
sabotage attempted assassinations even
coup plots across europe
and deborah the finger also being
pointed further at the russian
government agencies today by the
european court of human rights
yes it's quite timely isn't it that the
european court of human rights has come
out today with its ruling on another
case of a successful assassination this
time blamed on russia back in 2006 of
the former russian spy alexander
litvinenko you'll remember he was
poisoned with polonium 210 after
drinking green tea at the millennium
hotel in london and the uk has
accused russia russian agents of being
involved in that attack there was a
public inquiry that came out firmly
saying that this was a russian
state-sponsored assassination on the
streets of the uk and today the european
court of human rights ruling that yes
there is no other plausible explanation
than that this was a russian state
attack russia it has to be said
continues to deny these allegations not
just in relation to litvinenko but also
firmly in relation to sergey skripal but
make no mistake this is a a big day in
terms of the uk and the human the
european court of human rights calling
out russia and saying that actually they
believe that they were involved in these
two significant attacks on the uk
and deborah
what is like the impact going to be of
this sort of double whammy of
accusations against the russian state
well there will be the out the usual
outcries and the usual denials i imagine
it's interesting um the timing of this
because like i said at the beginning the
the i the fact the belief that there was
at least one other suspect a third
suspect has long been known and long
been talked about but for the uk to come
out and and call
call it out and accuse him by name not
just using his alias but using what they
say is his real name saying directly
that he was a member of the gru it is
obviously it's for the police there they
say they're doing their job they're
following the evidence and they want to
bring justice but in terms of
geopolitics this is the uk very much
pushing back on what they see as an
attack an attacker below the threshold
of war but an attack nonetheless against
the uk with what they believe was a
russian state authorization of using a
chemical weapon novichok a nerve agent
on on british street that
yes it it it was unsuccessful in its
attempt to assassinate sergey skripal
who was a believed to be a double a
russian double agent hired by mi6
and also but seriously injured him plus
his daughter and the police officer but
don't forget four months after that
attack
a perfume bottle thought to have been
used by the would-be assassins was then
discovered by a local man handed to his
girlfriend dawn sturgis and she sprayed
it on herself and then died so this is
serious consequences here and clearly
the uk isn't letting go and wants russia
to cooperate and to to allow a proper
investigation